بيوزع نيمار جول
[تصفيق]
ميسي بطاقه صفراء
كيف يمكن لبطاقه صفراء يتلقاها ميسي في
احد ملاعب اوروبا ان تعود بمكسب مادي على
مواطن فقير في افريقيا
[موسيقى]
صناعه عملاقه ترفع البابا الى مصافي
الاثرياء وترمي اخرين الى ادنى درجات
العوازه تدير لها شركات تجاريه ضخمه
وعصابات من المافيا ويتورط فيها لاعبون
مشهورين في اللعبه الربح فيها السهل
المنال لا يحتاج الى جهد او خبره يعتمد
على قراءه النتائج السابقه وتحليل اداء
الفرق واللاعبين احيانا
[موسيقى]
حسن الطالع في اكثر الالقاب بعد رواتها من
الاثرياء الطامعيين في مزيد من الملايين
واخرون فقراء يبحثون عن قليل مال القياس
الدر مقام تعالوا الى استكشف عالم
المراهنات في كره القدم
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
بدات هذه الصناعه الضخمه في الرياضات
الحديثه مطلع القرن الثامن عشر وتحديدا في
سباقات الخيول التي كانت منتشره في
بريطانيا حينها اما تاريخ دخولها على كره
القدم فيرجح انه بدا مطلع القرن الماضي
حين كانت تقام بين الجدران المغلقه وفي
الازقه والشوارع الى ان شرعت قانونيه في
انجلترا بعد سن قانون المؤامره عام 1960
اكتسبت قوه اكبر مع ظهور البث التليفزيوني
للمباريات وبلغت اوجهها مع دخول الانترنت
الذي سهل رواجها وجذب شريحه جديده من
ملايين الاشخاص في بدء المراهقات فما على
المراه سوى ان يسجل في احد من الصوت
المراه هنا او المواقع او التطبيقات التي
تمنح حسابا مجانيا للتجريب واعتياد
المقاومه وتتيح له اشكال متعدده من هنادي
مقابله مبلغ ثابتا يدفعه يتبخر هذا المبلغ
اذا خسر ويتضاعف اذا اصاب التوقعاته يدفع
10 يورو مورانا على فوز مانشستر يونايتد
مثلا وقد يرتفع المبلغ الى 30 يورو او
اكثر اذا ما فاز او تذهب اليوروهات العشره
السوداء اذا مني الفريق بالخساره الربح
يزيد وفقا للمبلغ الاولاني دخول المراهنه
ودقه النتيجه المتوقعه والتفاصيل التي
يراهم عليها مثل تحديد البطاقات الصفراء
والحمراء التي ينالها كل فريق واي فريقين
سيتمكن من التسجيل اولا واللاعب الذي
سيحرز هاتريك او من سيسجل والتشكيله
الاساسيه ومن سيشارك من لاعبي الاحتياط
وعدد ضربات الجزاء المحتسبه وغيرها
يا روني الله
[موسيقى]
كوره جول كوره جول رونالدو رونالدو
مثل تحديد بطل الدوري ويعتمد في ذلك على
قوه النادي الذي رهن عليها ونتائجه
السابقه
عام 2016 شهد اكبر رهان على الاطلاق في
كره القدم حينرانا احد المشجعين على فوز
نادي الاستر سيتي بالدوري الانجليزي وفاز
بمبلغ 72,000 جنيه استرليني بعد توقعه
تتويج الثعلب مع ان توقعات تحقيقه للدوري
كانت واحد من خمسه الاف فقط
[موسيقى]
للصلاه بارونات ورجال واشخاص فازوا
بالملايين
بينهم الذي جمع ثروه طائله بعد ان دخل
السوق عام 2001 وصار فيما بعد مالكا لنادي
براند فورد الانجليزيه
والذي اسس شركه سمارت اود المختصه بتقديم
تحليل البيانات والاستشارات للمقامرين في
كره القدم وفيها عشرات التطبيقات والمنصات
التي تدعي الموثوقيه مثل سكايبات
وغيرها الكثير وتضم ملايين المشتركين
الراغبين في المقامره وتحقيق الربح هذه
الظاهره غير منتشره على صعيد الدوريات
العربيه عنا بسبب تجريم المغامره في معظم
البلدان العربيه وعدم وجود مواقع محليه
متخصصه بالريالات
العالميه ويتعاملون مع السماسيره يدرون
بهانات من منازلهم او في الاماكن العامه
في حين يلجا المحبوب كره القدم غير
الراغبين بالمقامره والذين يعشقون الادلاء
بتوقعاتهم على العاب كره القدم التفاعليه
وعلى راسها
بريميرليج وفوتبول مانجر وغيرها من
الالعاب التي لا ربح فيها ولا خساره
يتورط بعض اللاعبين احيانا في دخوله هذا
السوق اما بالمراهنه والمغامره مثل
الاشخاص العاديين واما بالتاثير في نتيجه
المباراه لصالح احدى الجنوب
مطلع العام الجاري اتهم تحقيق للاتحاد
الانجليزي لعب ارسنال السويسي جراني
بطاقه الصفراء بعد ضغط من المافيا
الالبانيه تزامنا مع ارتفاع الرهان على
حصوله على البطاقه بمبالغ وصلت الى 52000
جنيه
تدفع بالعمولات المشفره
لاعب اليوكاسل يونايتد الحريق
سرب خمر انتقاله الى نادي اتلتيكو مدريد
على احد مجموعات الدردشه في تطبيق واتساب
ما اشعل سوق المراهنات التي رهنت على
وجهته المقبله وادت الى تغريمه ب 70,000
جنيه استرليني لخلقه قواعد الاتحاد
الانجليزي
وفي عام 2019
كانت احد اسباب تشويه اللعبه التي احبها
الجميع وغير مفاهيمه مشاهده مباريات كره
القدم
المشارك فيها لا يشجع فريقا لشجره او حب
الانتماء بل يراها وسيله سهله للربح
السريع دون قطره عرق واحده
ما جعل البعض يؤمنونها الى ان افتقروا
وتسببت في افراغ مدخرات اخرين وافلاسهم
[موسيقى]